je crois que le la chambre est que degré
dit que je ne connais d'ailleurs même
pas moi même avec vous avez visité
foncier tout à fait temporaire
quant à la somptuosité de mon
appartement ça se résume ce que vous
devez cadre est actuellement dans votre
caméra
c'est donc ici que vous travaillez que
vous créez vos qu'est ce que vous
écrivez
depuis une dizaine d'années je crois je
suis embrouillé avec les dates mais je
crois que j'habite ici depuis une
dizaine d'années à peu près eh bien oui
c'est sur ce même canapé que nous avons
écrit toutes nos dernières pièces en
général c'est grédy qui tient la plume
sur ses genoux nous n'avons pas de
bureau pas de table de travail
donc oui c'est là exactement le lieu de
travail
pourquoi est ce que c'est vous qui tenez
la plume c'est un parce que je suis
myope s'en douter et maniaque et puis
voilà je ne sais pas pourquoi oui j'ai
l'impression que je retiens mieux
les dialogues en face le mazari est
arrivé à pierre de tenir la plume et
d'écrire mu même alors si vous êtes
toujours d'accord sur le thème de vos
pièces
est-ce que sur le plan personnel vous
avez des affinités
oui les affinités mais nous avons des
goûts très différents nous avons
d'ailleurs des amis tre nous partageons
quelques vieux amis mais les devis et
les deux façons de vivre sont très
différentes que j'aime beaucoup ce grand
tableau qui est au dessus de moi là
enfin tous les objets de son personnel
les objets que j'ai tu n'aimes pas tout
ce que j'ai n'aimait pas tout ce que
j'ai reçu presque qui excuse moi aussi
mais moi je ne suis pas du tout un
collectionneur vous savez pas tout sac
objets que vous verrez ici est un cadeau
ou un souvenir je le tiens ma famille il
ya très très peu de choses que j'ai
choisie ou achetés par où ça cette coupe
ce poisson japonais japonais oui oui
c'est un cadeau de grec d'ici alors peu
tannique les nouveaux porteurs avoué oui
l'évolution débarrasser et son puissant
comme il voyage beaucoup d'un
appartement à l'autre là il est toujours
sûr de le voir là est-ce que vous
souhaiteriez qu'il d'entorse en ont
écouté je ne leur ai pas dit mis à
l'honneur même pour faire plaisir à leur
ai dit si je ne l'aimais pas
j'aimais bien léché les brocanteurs il
ya longtemps tsai agents d une année ou
des grains 10,1 ici n'était pas là je
vous le dirai il a un très très très
grand sens artistique décorateur comme
vous avez pu le constater chez moi c'est
vraiment bien la peine mais nous
reviendrons chez vous prenez rendez-vous
suis sûr que le domaine surprise au
coeur est-ce que vous gardez tous les
deux ou l'un plus que l'autre des
souvenirs de votre travail en commun
beaucoup de vos pièces pour ses nuits
les archives les archives c'est pierre
jullian n'est pas mal de photos j'ai
gardé beaucoup de coupures de presse je
tiens vous savez d'aidé scrapbook que
j'essaie de
garder à jour et dans lesquels on peut
retrouver à peu près toutes les étapes
essentielles de notre carrière
[Musique]